يومكم واهلا بكم الى الساعه الاخباريه
مفصله نخصص معظمها لتطورات المشهد
السوداني وهذه العناوين
اشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
في السودان رغم الهدنه المعلنه واعمده
دخان تتصاعد في الخرطوم
الجيش السوداني يقول ان دعم السريع فقد
نصف قدراته العسكريه منذ بدء الشبكات
الهلال الاحمر السوداني يدعو طرفي الصراع
الالتزامي بالهدنه لتسهيل عمل منظمات
الاغاثه
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
النقابات الفرنسيه تتوقع مشاركه اكثر من
مليون ونصف شخص في تظاهرات ضد نظام
التقاعد الجديد
[موسيقى]
رغم الهدنه المعلنه في السودان لمده
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه الا ان مراسل العربيه
رصد اشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش ودعم
السريع فيما تصاعدت اعمده دخان في سماء
العاصمه الخرطوم ومع ذلك قال الجيش ان
الوضع العمليات مستقر في جميع الولايات
اما الاوضاع الانسانيه فحدث ولا حرج ما
دفع الهلال الاحمر السوداني الى دعوه طرفي
الصراع الالتزام بالهدنه لتسهيل عمل
المنظمات الاغاثيه
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعه المرسى
شامباك المواطنين والسكان في المنطقه مثل
التنبات ومناطق المجاوره
مباشره من النيل شيلوا مويه
من النيل واللي هنا من المرسى وانت ماشي
بتعاني جدعاني شديد جدعان
تتحرك بيه من المناطق الصدريه
وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
اكد بيان الجيش السوداني ان الاوضاع حاليا
تشهد هدوءا حذرا وهي مستقره في جميع
ولايات البلاد وبحسب البيان حشدت قوات
الدعم السريع اكثر من 65 الف عنصر والفين
مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل الخامس عشر
من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع التصدي
لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان الجيش
تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال ان يخفض
قدرات الدعم السريع القتاليه الى النصف
مضيفا انه تم احباط عده تحركات لتعزيزات
عسكريه لقوات دعم السريع كانت قادمه من
اتجاه الغرب الى الخرطوم
من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني
العميد نبيل عبد الله قال ان القوات
المسلحه تسيطر على 80% من ولايتي الخرطوم
وغار دارفور السيطره كامله على كل
الولايات 17 والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
الفردفان غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير متغير الاخير الذي تمصل في اندلاع
الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان يجري
احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك عن
طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه يعني
تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما فيها
القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه وحتى
منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس صحيحا
وتواصل
وحداتا في منطقه الخرطوم بحري بينما تستمر
الاشتباكات المنقطعه بين الجيش ودعم
السريع في مناطق متفرقه بالعاصمه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
قبل ذلك نشر الجيش السوداني لقطات لقائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وهو يشرف على
السير العمليات العسكريه من احد مراكز
القياده
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى الخرطوم معنا من هناك الصحه في
عمار ابو شيبه عمار مرحبا بك معنا في سياق
هذه التغطيه بدايه ما هي ابرز الخروقات
التي تم تسجيلها الى الان في الخرطوم
ربما قبل قليل استمعنا الى تحليق للطيران
الحربي كان قبل دقائق من الان هذا كان قبل
دقائق من الان وفي صباح اليوم كانت هنالك
عدد من الخروقات لهذه الهدنه السادسه من
خلال الاشتباكات التي جرت في منطقه جنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم وفي عدد من وسط العاصمه
الخرطوبه ايضا كذلك في معروف بمحيط
القياده العامه ومطار الخرطوم الان
استمعنا قبل لحظات الى تحليق للطيران
الحربي يبدو ان هنالك اهدافا على الارض
رصدت يتم من خلالها التعامل معها من خلال
الطيران الحربي
طيب عمار ماذا عن الوضع الانساني اخر
المعطيات المتعلقه بالوضع الانساني
المدنيين حتى الساعه
نعم في جوله قمنا بها صباح اليوم في عدد
من المناطق في الشرق العاصمه الخرطوم
الوضع الانساني ينذر بكثير جدا من المخاطر
الخاصه اذا ما قسمناه الى عده مستويات
خاصه على المستوى الانساني الصحي هنالك
عدد من المستشفيات الان هي خارج الخدمه
كثير جدا من المناشدات وكثير جدا من
المطالب اتتحدث في هذه النقطه عن ضروره
يعني تجسير عدد من الطرق يتم من خلالها
الوصول عبر الممرات الامنه للكادر الطبي
لهذه المستشفيات هنالك ايضا على المستوى
الغذائي في في شرق العاصمه الخرطوم وفي
عدد من احياء العاصمه الخرطوم ايضا كثيره
جدا من النواقص لعدد من الاحتياجات
الضروريه فيما يتعلق بالخبز فيما يتعلق
ايضا بشحفي غاز الطبخ وايضا كذلك على
المستوى الامداد الكهربائي والامداد
المائي ما زال العدد بين الاحياء تعاني
العطش وما زالت عدد من الاحياء تنقطع فيها
الكهرباء بشكل كبير ولساعات طوال طيب عمار
طالما تتحدث عن
نقص في بعض الاغذيه الرئيسيه والمستلزمات
اليوم هل من تراجع لهذه الاسعار خصوصا بعد
ان ارتفعت بشكل جنوني يعني حوالي 300% في
الايام السابقه والاسابيع السابقه
الاسعار بطبيعتها وبطبيعه هذه الازمه لا
تتراجع للوراء هي تذهب وتتقدم للامام كل
يوم هنالك سعر جديد لعدد من السلع كثير من
الموردين الذين
تحدثت معهم يقولون بانهم يعانون في ايصال
هذه السلع من عمليه المواصلات والطرق
والوقود وغلاء في هذه العمليه هذا ما يقول
لارتفاع الاسعار مع الندره التي تتوفر
بشكل واضح من خلال هذه المواد الغذائيه
وهذه الاحتياجات الضروريه هذا هو الحديث
الدائري الان ولكن الاسعار التي تتراجع
للاوراء هي تذهب للامام تتقدم وترتفع يوما
بعد يوم في كثير جدا من المناحي خاصه
الاسواق الصغيره التي استطاعت ان تعمل
ولولي ساعات معينه ولكن لا تتوفر فيها كل
الاحتياجات وان توفرت فهي باهظه الثمن
وهذا يشير الى عدم ضبط ورقابه واضحه في
خلال هذا السوق ويشير ايضا كذلك الى غياب
ربما الامن بشكل واضح مما اثر على عمليه
استمرار وتغذيه هذه هذه الاسواق وهذه
المحاله التجاريه التي اذا ما عملت فهي
تعمل ولو بشكل فعال بشكل جزئي ولكنه فعال
ولكنها ايضا لا تعاني من ندره وتعاني من
ارتفاع لكن كان هناك حديث وصور وفيديوهات
عن انتشار قوات الشرطه الم يساهم ذلك نوعا
ما في استتباب الامن في بعض الاسواق اقله
لشعور الناس بالاطمئنان ربما
نعم هذه القوات نشرت في مدينه ام درمان
وهي منطقه يسيطر عليها الجيش وانفتح في
عدد كثير وكبير من شوارع المدينه واحياء
المدينه واعادت فيها الحياه ربما بالشكل
التدريجي واستطاعت الشرطه ان تؤمن عديد من
الممتلكات في تلك المناطق
لخلوها من الاشتباكات العسكريه واستطاعت
ايضا كذلك ان تسهم في عمليه التمرير كثير
جدا من الممرات الانسانيه واعاده
المستشفيات وحتى تامين الاسواق من عمليات
السلب والنهب التي كانت قد جرت بسبب
الاشتباكات التي دارت في تلك الاوقات اما
في المناطق التي تتاثر ما زالت بعمليات
الاشتباك العسكري ما زالت فيها ربما بنسبه
كبيره غياب للامن والامان وغياب ايضا كذلك
الى ربما تامين الطرق تامين الممتلكات
تامين المستشفيات تامين المرافق الصحيه
تامين حتى الاسواق الصغيره والمحال
التجاريه التي ما زالت موجوده في هذه
المناطق وربما فيها عدد من البضائع وعدد
من ربما الاشياء التي تم تخزينها من خلال
الايام الماضيه طيب عمار ماذا عن الخدمه
البنكيه عمل المصارف حتى يتسنى للجاليات
السودانيه في الخارج والرعايه ان يقدموا
مساعدات لاهاليهم ومن يحتاجون في السودان
اليوم
قبل دقائق من الان كان هنالك بيان للبنك
المركزي تحدث فيه بشكل واضح بان الخدمه قد
عادت في عدد من الولايات وهذا ياتي
بالتزامن ايضا مع بيان الجيش الذي ذكر فيه
بانه يسيطر على عدد كبير جدا من الولايات
باستثناء العاصمه الخرطوم التي ربما فيها
الكثير من المناطق التي تخرج عن سيطره
الجيش وتحدث هذا البيان بيان البنك
المركزي عن ان الخدمات عادت لعدد من
البنوك وعدد من الفروع للبنك المركزي
والبنوك الاخرى وتفعلت هذه الخدمات في عدد
من الولايات التي لم تتضرر او لم تجري
فيها اشتباكات عسكريه واقعه على ارض
الميدان على مستوى العاصمه الخرطوم لم
نلحظ انها البنوك قطعت واشتغلت من جديد
وقدمت خدماتها في كثير جدا من المناطق
ربما ما زال الكثيرون هنا يتعاملون مع
التطبيقات البنكيه وهذه تتاثر بشكل واضح
وكبير بحركه ربما الاتصالات وسير وخدمات
الاتصالات
التي تتقطع وتعود بفعل الاشتباكات
العسكريه وبفعل انقطاع الكهرباء لساعات
طويله وبفعل تهدم عدد من محطات التغذيه
لخدمات الاتصالات وهذا ما اثر ايضا في
عمليات البيع والشراء بشكل واضح طيب عمار
معك الى الشق السياسي هل من تفاصيل
معلومات اي اصوات تعلو من قبل القوى
السياسيه
لمبادرات تحضر داخليا على صعيد رسمي من
قبل بعض الاحزاب في السودان
نعم يعني هنالك كان حديث بالامس للسيد
خالد عمر يوسف الناطق باسم العمليه
السياسيه الاتفاق الايطالي الحديث الان
يبدو ان من السياسيين ممكننا خاصه في
واوقات الهدن وان كانت هدى غير كليه بشكل
واضح ويتم الالتزام بها ربما اذا ما تم
الالتزام بها يمكن لسياسيين ان يمرروا عدد
من القنوات الاتصال وان يخلقوا عدد من
العلاقات التي يمكن ان تصل بين الطرفين
لعديد من المفاهمات كان هناك حديث عن ربما
عديد من المبادرات التي قد تجري في عدد من
الدول الاقليميه المجاوره او الفاعله في
المنطقه خصوصا وان الكثير من السياسيين
والعسكريين حتى تجمعهم علاقات ربما جيده
وممتازه مع عدد من الدول التي يمكن ان
تؤثر على القرار السياسي ويمكن ان تؤثر
على القرار اصحاب القرار والقاده
الموجودين الان في اطار البحث عن عمليه
سياسيه البحث عن تسويه جديده ربما تفضي
الى وقف اطلاق دائم للنار او تفضي الى
مفاوضات جديده من خلالها يتم وضع بنود
محدده وبيان الجيش قبل قليل ربما اشار في
عدد من النقاط الى عدد من النقاط السياسيه
التي تحدثت بان الجيش ربما الان قد اتخذ
خطوات واضحه في التعامل مع هذه المعركه
واشار ايضا من خلال نقاط تفصيليه الى ان
ارض المعركه والاستقرار الاني يسود فيها
بشكل واضح وكبير وانه استطاع تدمير عدد
بنسبه كبيره وعدد من المركبات المركبات
لاقوات الدعم السريع وفي الجانب الاخر
تحدثت قوات الدعم السريع ايضا انها ما
زالت تسيطر على عدد من المواقع
الاستراتيجيه وما زالت تستطيع الحركه
بمرونه وما زالت تستطيع ان تذهب الى
العديد من المناطق في العاصمه الخرطوم
وتعلم من خلالها وجودها هذان البيان
يشيران مع الفعل السياسي الذي تحدث عنه
الناطق باسم العمليه السياسيه الشيران الى
ان جميع الاطراف ربما يذهبان او يذهبوا
الى عمليه تفاوض مشروطه او دقيقه بحسب
كثير من التحليل وبحسب كثير جدا من اراء
الخبراء الذي التي طالعناها والتي تنشر في
الساعات القادمه من خلالها نستطيع ان
نستبين اكثر في هذه العمليه السياسيه انا
اكتب في معكم واشكرك جزيلا شكرا الخرطوم
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
وطبعا نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
لتصاعد اعمده الدخان في الخرطوم مع
الانباء التي تفيد بس معدويا انفجارات
وتصاعد اعمده الدخان في محيط القصر
الجمهوري بالعاصمه السودانيه ننقل لكم هذه
المشاهد مباشره على ما يبدو هناك تصاعد
لدخان ليس بالكثيف اذا ما قارناه بالمشاهد
والصور التي كنا ننقلها في ايام سابقه حتى
هذه الساعه هناك انباء عن دوي في جارات
وايضا تصاعد لاعمده الدخان في محيط القصر
الجمهوري دائما مكانه تتركز الاشتباكات في
محيط القصر الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه
في ظل تبادل الجانبين الطرفين العسكريين
المتحاربين الاتهامات بانه هو من خلق هذه
الهدنه طبعا في ظل الانباء التي تتحدث عن
ان الاجواء الميدانيه وحتى المعيشيه
بالنسبه للمواطنين بدات تتحسن اكثر فاكثر
مع مرور الهدنه حين تلد هدنه اخرى ولكن
هذه الهدن توصف بانها هدى حذره حتى هذه
الساعه وهي قابله لاختراق في اي وقت على
امل من قبل الجهود العربيه الدوليه
والامميه حتى للوصول الى وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار وحتى التفاوض بين الطرفين حتى هذه
الساعه نتابع معكم هذه الصور دخان يتصاعد
في سماء العاصمه ولكنه ليس بالكثيف حتى
هذه الساعه رغم ان المعلومات تفيد بدوي
انفجارات وتصاعد اعمده للدخان في محيط
القصر الجمهوري بالذات في العاصمه
السودانيه
ومع استمرار المواجهات تظاهر العشرات امام
البيت الابيض في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
لمطالبه السلطات الامريكيه بالتدخل لوقف
القتال في السودان بين الجيش وقوه الدعم
السريع
وهذه فيديوهات اخرى ننقلها لكم مباشره
الان ضمن هذه التغطيه ايضا من وسط العاصمه
السودانيه حيث تفيد الانباء الاخيره بسماع
دوي انفجارات وتصاعد اعمده دخان في محيط
القصر الجمهوري بالخرطوم رغم ان الهدنه
الجديده في السودان دخلت حيز التنفيذ طبعا
في جديد الاخبار والمعلومات المتعلقه
بالمعطيات العسكريه الميدانيه على الارض
كان الجيش السوداني وفي بيانه الاخير تحدث
عن ان الاوضاع مستقره في جميع ولايات
السودان وبانه ايضا تمكن من تخفيض قدرات
الدعم السريع القتاليه الى النصف تقريبا
اي حوالي 45% الى 55 في المئه كانت هذه
جديد الاخبار المتعلقه بالمعطيات العسكريه
الميدانيه في السودان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يواجه الكثير من السودانيين مصاعب حقيقيه
في ممارسه حياتهم اليوميه بسبب الاقتتال
الدائر بين الجيش ودعم السريع حيث يواجه
عمال الاجره اليوميه معاناه مع استمرار
للشبكات حيث اختفت فرص العمل بسبب الحرب
بعد العيد لحد هنا ما في شيء
المواصلات عشان تجي السوق ده وترجع السوق
من القريب ده بالنسبه لمحل انا اسكن ذليته
بفضل اكون قاعد في بيتي
هذا وتتواصل عمليات الاجلاء في ام درمان
حيث قرر الالاف من السودانيين نزوحا من
مناطقهم هربا من الاقتتال الدائر فيما
يتجه كثيرون الى من خلال حافلات لنقل
الركاب باتت تكلفتها اغلى من المعتاد بسبب
نقص الوقود هذا ويقول الاهالي في ام درمان
ان العائلات تتجه الى مواقف الحافلات سيرا
على الاقدام بسبب عدم توفر وسائل النقل مع
استمرار للشبكات المسلحه
الخرطوم للولايات فبرده يعني الحاجه صعبه
شديد يعني اول كلمه
دفار باقل تذكره للبيض بعشر ألف فما بالك
يعني باقي التفاصيل حتكون كيف ولا
الباصات اسعار حتكون كيف
نوجهها الولايات حاليا يعني الباصات كلها
بتمشي بورسودان 12 13 مليار لو بنفسنا
اما في بورتسودان يكافح حشرات الالاف من
الرعايه الاجانب لمغادره السودان في ظل
استمرار القتال حيث تجمعت حشود من
المدنيين في ميناء بورتسودان الذي يعد
ملجا يتجه اليه الكثيرون على امل مغادره
البلاد عن طريق البحر
السودان عايش في لحظه رعب حقيقيه
يعني انا بتكلم عن جثث في الشوارع
شمينا روحت الجثث واحنا جايين من الخرطوم
الضرب القذف يعني بجد السودان في حاله
تعترف حقيقيه
3400 العدد كبير جوا البناء وبره وعلى
الكورنيش الناس في الارض فرامل اطفال
مسنين مرضى بشكل عام احنا قاعدين هنا في
مكان يعني الله يجزاهم الخير يوفرون اصلا
مكان لكن احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني اغلب
الناس قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين اماكن
بعيده اغلبنا اتين من الخرطوم
بين عمليات النزوح والاجلاء هناك قصص
كثيره يعيشها المتجهون من الخرطوم الى
المعابر حيث تعرض العديد منهم خلال رحله
الطريق لقطاع طرق وعمليات نهب واستغلال من
تجار الحرب نتابع
مسيره شاقه رحله لجوء بدات من هنا من
سوريا الى السودان لجا الى الخرطوم قبل
سنوات هربا من الحرب لينتهي به الحال في
مواجهه حرب اخرى اما ننصح
بالحرب عيسى شاب سوري استقر به الحال بين
اهالي ولايه كسلا تبعد 700 كيلومتر عن
معارك الخرطوم لكن قبل وصوله الى مدينه
حلفا عاش قصه نزوح مضطربه
المعارك كانت على مرمى حجر منه قرر العوده
الى سوريا عبر رحلات اجلاء من بورتسودان
لكن ما كان ينتظره اسوا
في الشارع
[موسيقى]
سرقت
المسار المائي مئات الالاف يرغبون بالعوده
لكن الطريق الى المعابر ان لم تكن مدروسه
امنيا محفوفه بقطاع الطرق او مفخخه بتجار
حرب تجار بات لا ينقلون النازحين الى
بالاف الدولارات ما جعلهم غنيمه لعمليات
نهب لا تصدها هدى غذاء السالم العربيه
هذا وتتواصل عمليات اجلاء رعايه دول
الاجنبيه من السودان عن طريق عدد من
المنافذ ابرزها ميناء ومطار بورسودان وحسب
احصائيات رسميه فان نحو عشره الاف من
رعايه دول تم اجلائهم عبر البحر واكثر من
7000 عبر ميناء بورسودان في وقت يستمر
توافد الاف السوريين واليمنيين نحو مدينه
بورتسودان لاستكمال اجراءات اجلائهم نحو
اليوم العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه
دول العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه من شرق
السودان الى عدد من الدول في المنطقه اكثر
من نحو عشره الاف من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه
تم اجلائهم خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
عبر ميناء بورتسودان وما يقدر لاكثر من
6000 غادروا عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي الى
وجهات دوليه مختلفه ومع استمرار عمليات
الاجلاء الا ان مئات من الاسر السوريه
واليمنيه ما تزال حتى اليوم استكمال
اجراءات مغادرتها للبلاد احنا مو طالبين
اكثر من نوع يتم اجلانه احنا مطالبين من
اي بلد يقعدوا في ناس او يستضيفوهم شكرا
احنا بس بدنا ممر امن من هنا الى الحدود
السوريه وشكرا البعض فضل البقاء داخل مركز
التسجيل والحصر هنا واخرون عملت السلطات
المحليه على توفير دور مؤقته لوائهم في ظل
ظروف يحاول الجهد الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه
بورسودان تخفيف وطاتها على العائلات
والنساء والاطفال الموجودين حاليا بشرق
السودان نزار البداوي لقناتي العربيه
والحدث مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
انا في سياق هذه التغطيه هل ارتفعت وتيره
عمليات الاجلاء من بورتسودان كمحطه اولى
عمليه تفويج من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وعمليه مغادره ايضا عدد من رعايه الدول
الاجنبيه من العاصمه الخرطوم ومن عدد من
مدن السودان ما زالت مستمره في اطار
التنسيق بالطبع بين الجيش وبين عديد
المؤسسات والبعثات والدبلوماسيه نحن الان
هنا في مدينه بورسودان بشرق السودان سناخذ
جوله لنتعرف على واقع هذا المركز الرئيسي
الذي يضم مئات من الاسر الذي التي بدات في
التوافد الى مدينه بورسودان نبدا بالجهد
الشعبي الذي يوازي هذه الاعداد الكثيفه
الان هيئه الموانئ البحريه ممثله في غرفه
الطوارئ عامله على توفير هذا المستشفى
المؤقت وهذه الغرفه المؤقته للطوارئ
للتعامل مع عدد من الحالات التي قد ترد
الى هذه المنطقه حالات لسوريين
وللسودانيين حتى تقدم لهم الخدمات في هذا
المركز الذي انشئ قبل يومين في هذه
المنطقه التي تضم ايضا كما ذكرنا عددا من
السوريين وعددا من اليمنيين وايضا اضيفت
اليهم نسبه اخرى من المقيمين السودانيين
الذين يحاولون ايضا عبر هذا المركز ان
يغادروا هذه المنصه هنا في شرق السودان
الى عدد من الدول عبر من بورسودان نتابع
ايضا هذا هو الجهد الرسمي والجهد الشعبي
الذي يتوفر الان حتى اللحظه اما في الداخل
فنلاحظ ايضا عبر الصوره بان هنالك ايضا
المئات من الاسر السوريه واليمنيه ما زالت
تواصل الحضور الى هذه النقطه الى هذا
المركز الرئيس هنا في نادي هيئه الموانئ
البحريه بمدينه بورسودان حالات الاقتضاض
ما تزالوا ماثله لمئات من الاسر اكثر من
4000 اسره حسب الاحصائيات غير رسميه من
ابناء الجاليه يؤكدون بانها موجوده في هذه
المدينه في بورسودان الكره الان يطالب
ويناشد عبر الاعلام خاصه من ابناء الجاليه
السوريه هنا في مدينه
الاسراع في توفيق اوضاع السوريين الذين
وصلوا الى هذه المدينه لنحو اكثر من
ثمانيه ايام وكذلك ابناء الجاليه اليمنيه
الذين طالبوا السلطات في اليمن والسلطات
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايضا
بالاسهام والاستعجال في توفير او توفيق
اوضاع عدد من الاسر وعدد من اللاجئين وعدد
من الذين يرغبون في مغادره السودان خلال
الساعات كيف يتم استيعاب هذه الاعداد
الهائله وهذا الاقتضاد من حيث عدد
الراغبين في المغادره كم من الوقت مثلا
يمضون في المدينه وفي الميناء قبل
المغادره
نزار هل تسمعني
طيب قطع الخط يبدو انه فقدنا الاتصال في
نزار كنا نتابع معكم هذه المشاهد من مدينه
بورسودان حيث توافد الاف الجنسيات نتحدث
عن سوريين يمنيين نحو المدينه الاستكمال
عمليات اجراءات الاجلاء حتى هذه الساعه
كنا نتابعها معكم عبر مراسل العربيه نزار
الى متابعه جهود السعوديه في عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره افاده مراسل العربيه
بوصول سفينه حربيه امريكيه تقل 318 اشخاص
من سته عشره جنسيه قادمه من السودان الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي اضافنا جده استقبلت 26
سفينه اجلاء قادمه من السودان حتى الان
بالاضافه الى 49 رحله اجلاء جويه من
بورتسودان وصلت الى جده تقل اكثر من
2200 شخص كما ستغادر طائر عسكريه هنديه
ستغادر من جده الى السودان لاجلاء 140
شخصا
[موسيقى]
سودانيه
نعود معكم لنتابع هذه الصور والمشاهد
مباشره من العاصمه السودانيه حيث تصاعد
لاعمده الدخان ومنذ ساعه تقريبا كانت
الانباء تفيد بتصاعد اعمده الدخان في
العاصمه تحديدا في محيط القصر الجمهوري
حيث تتركز الاشتباكات في هذه المنطقه وفي
محيط القصر اكثر من غيرها في العاصمه
السودانيه وطبعا اذا ما قارنا اعمده
الدخان بفترات سابقه مثلا قبل نصف ساعه من
الان اصبح دخان يتصاعد بكثافه اكثر ورغم
ان هذه الصور وهذه المشاهد اذا ما قورنت
بايام سابقه تعتبر افضل الى حد ما طبعا
الهدنه الجديده في السودان دخلت ايضا حيز
التنفيذ على امل من قبل كل الاطراف ان يتم
تحقيق وقف دائم هذه المره لاطلاق نار وليس
هدنه فقط وفي المقابل جديد الانباء تتحدث
ان الجيش يقول بان الاوضاع مستقره وانه
مسيطر على حوالي 80% فيما يتحدث بان قوات
الدعم السريع فقدت نحو نصف قدراتها
العسكريه القتاليه اي بنسبه 45 ل 55 في
المئه حتى هذه الساعه طبعا هذه المشاهد
تاتيكم مباشره من العاصمه السودانيه
اصبحت مشاهد معتاده في السودان لتصاعد
اعمده الدخان وايضا الانباء تفيد بسماع
دوي قذائف وانفجارات ايضا في العاصمه
السودانيه طبعا الاشتباكات وايضا احتدام
المعارك تتركز في ولايه الخرطوم بمدنها
الثلاث اذا ما تحدثنا عن العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم خرطوم بحري وام درمان
ايضا العاصمه المثلثه ايضا كان في
اشتباكات في غرب دارفور ولكنها انحصلت
قبليه
تتزامن مع هذا الصراع المحتدم منذ الخامس
عشر من ابريل تم احتوائها الى حد ما رغم
هذه الاجواء التي نتابعها الان ولكن
الجهود مستمره لمحاوله ايجاد حل يرضي
الطرفين وايضا يجعلهما يوقفان العمليات
العسكريه والذهاب الى التفاوض في وقت لاحق
كخطوه مستقبليه وخطوه لاحقه لكن عمليات
الاجلاء ما زالت مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
وايضا كنا نتابع معكم هذه الصور من
بورتسودان حيث اصبح وكانه المعبر الرئيسي
لمغادره الراغبين في مغادره البلاد من
جنسيات مختلفه ليس فقط من السودانيين بل
هناك العديد من الجنسيات منهم يمنيون
وايضا سوريون كما كنا نشاهد قبل قليل مع
مراسل العربيه الذي رصد لنا التطورات من
هناك
الان في متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه قال
المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني
اسامه ابو بكر قال في تصريحاته للعربيه ان
التقديرات تشير لوجود نحو 500 جثه لقتله
الاشتباكات اضاف ان جثميد قتل الاشتباكات
تمثل مشكله كبرى
مختلف المؤينات الطبيه والمستلزمات الطبيه
والشحنه القادمه من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر هي فيها كل المستلزمات الطبيه حسب
الاولويات المطروحه بحكم انه اللجنه
الدوليه لحمه عندها جثه قائمه منذ عشرات
السنين في السودان ونعمل مع بعض سويا لذلك
كل الاشياء الجايه في الشحنه دي هي اشياء
ربح اولويه طبعا الشحنه يعني
هي 8 طن او 8000 كيلو يعني وبالتالي حتحدث
انفراج كبير جدا
ابو بكر قال ايضا العربيه ان المساعدات
الطبيه المرسله من الصليب الاحمر تمثل
انفراجه كبيره للازمه الصحيه في السودان
والتي تاثرت بشكل كبير بسبب الاقتتال
الدائر بين قوات الجيش ودعم السريع
لمساعدات الحتجي من برنامج الغذاء العالمي
او اي من المؤسسات العالميه اكيد حتستفيد
منها
المواطنين وضحايا النزاع المسلح ودائما
نحن عندنا الشراكات مع كل هذه المنظمات
التابعه للامم المتحده وغيرها فان هي
بتعتمد على الهلال الاحمر بالذات في توزيع
المساعدات سواء كانت مساعده صحيه او
انسانيه على مستوى السودان فضلا عن
الخرطوم لانه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
يعتمد في عمله اساسا على متطوعين متخصصين
في مجالات مختلفه يبلغ عددهم النصف مليون
متطوره في جميع انحاء السودان
السودان نظام الرعايه الصحيه على وشك
الانهيار الصحه العالميه اكدت وقوع 26
هجوما على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه منذ
اندلاع الصراع بالسودان
وتقول ان المستشفيات تعرضت للقصف واغلق
ثلثاها في الخرطوم نقابه اطباء السودان
حذرت من الانهيار الكامل للنظام الرعايه
الصحيه
الصليب الاحمر العاملون في مجال الرعايه
الصحيه في السودان يفعلون المستحيل يعتنون
بالجرحى بدون ماء وكهرباء وامدادات طبيه
اساسيه
منظمات غير حكوميه تبذل جهودا لانقاذ
القطاع الصحي في السودان في ظل المعارك
المتواصله
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود قالت انها تبرعت
بمستلزمات طبيه لثلاثه مستشفيات في
الخرطوم
ومن الصليب الاحمر وصلت اول شحنه من
الامدادات الطبيه الى السودان
وطائره ثانيه ستنقل امدادات طبيه اضافيه
وموظفين في مجال الطوارئ
نذهب الى الخرطوم على من هناك دكتوره
هويدا محمد الحسن عضو منظمه اطباء السودان
من اجل حقوق الانسان دكتوره هويدا لطالما
حذرت نقابه اطباء السودان من ان انهيار
النظام الصحي بات وشيكا بالتالي ماذا يعني
ان ينهار النظام الصحي بشكل كامل في
السودان اذا لم يتم لملمه الامر
السلام عليكم
المجد الخلودي شهداء وعين الشفاء للمصابين
تحيه خاصه تحيه خاصه للكوادر الصحيه وتحيه
خاصه
المواطنين
وتحمل كل المخاطر
حقيقهم يقدمون ملحمه قمه الوفاء نحن
نستطيع ان نكون دوله يعني الان انا اعتبر
انه رجال الاحياء بمساعده الكوادر الطبيه
كونوا دوله لانهم يقدمون الامان للكوادر
الطبيه يعني هم يحرسون الكوادر الطبيه
فاسمحوا ان احيي هؤلاء لجان الاحياء حقيقه
الوضع الصحي يوميا يزداد سوء
ا ونحن نزداد قلقنا يعني القلق
المعينات لا نستطيع حتى جلبها من داخل
الخرطوم الان انا اتكلم عن منطقه شرق
النيل ادويه التخدير
تقريبا خلصت عندنا يعني تقريبا ما عندنا
والاندوتراكيه لتيوب الادنى بالنسبه
المصاب داخل العمليات خلصت من عندنا
تقريبا توجد يعني
تتحدثين عن نفاذ مخزون بعض الادويه وبعض
المستلزمات الطبيه لكن الم تستفيدوا
كاطباء كمستشفيات من الهدن والتي ما زالت
متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه رغم الخروقات من
البحث عن ممرات امنه لايصال ربما معونات
طبيه بينكم
الان صوت الرصاص اسمع صوت الرفاف الان انا
اسمع صورته وانا اعمل الان اسمع صوت
القنابل انا موجوده في منطقه ترجميل والان
صوت القنا
بل
ربما تسمعينه معي
وسمعنا انه في شحنه مساعدات وصلت عبر
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر قادمه من الاردن
وبعد اسبوعين طبعا وصلت هذه الشحنه والان
لا يدرون كيف تستطيع هذه الشغله ان تجد
طريق امن لتصل الينا وهذه الشؤون كميه من
المعدات الجراحيه
ومواد الطبيب والادويه لذلك نطلب منهم عبر
قناتكم ان يصلحوا لهذه
ان تصل الينا في الخرطوم يعني دكتور هويدا
اليوم عندما يعني تتحارب جهات عسكرية
تختلف فيما بين لكن ما الهدف من منع جهات
طبيه جسم طبي من ان يباشر عمله هل حصلتم
على اي تبرير او اي توضيح من اي من
الجهتين
الارض فارغه يعني من غيرنا يعني
لماذا
يعني يستهدف
ون اللي يستهدفون المستشفيات لا ندري يعني
ما هو الهدف من ذلك يعني
عبر القنوات الاخر
ى الحق
وبيه حتى لهؤلاء الشباب الموجودين بالحي
خاطروا خاطروا بانفسهم للذهاب الى الخرطوم
لجلب هذه المعينات لكنهم
لم تم تفتيشهم وتم ارجاعهم يعني الحمد لله
انهم وصلوا احياء
فلا ندري يعني الذين يمنعون الاعمال هي
قوات عسكريه لا ندري من فيهم يعني
لكنهم يقص
دون
نحن نشكرك نشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتوره هويدا
محمد الحسن عضو منظمه اقتباس السودان من
اجل حقوق الانسان
مع تفاقم الازمه الصحيه في السودان زادت
المخاوف من كارثه كبيره في توفير الدواء
مع دخول الاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش ودعم
السريع اسبوع الثالث
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
دين الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شحو الان المشكله بقت اكبر
تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار والصغار
على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه بارتفاع مستمر
فيما اصنافها المتوفره بانخفاض مقلق وجد
الاحداث الدوحه من سنين
مخلوط ومعاوى
الحقنوا عشان القليب
خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حته ما
لقينا وحتى عربيه زادت يتحركوا به عشان
يجيبوا لي الدواء ما في بنزين ما في هناك
طريقه نمرق من البلد عشان نمشي نفتش
الدواء نجيبه اما بالنسبه للمستشفيات فلا
يزال القليل منها الذي يعمل في الخرطوم
يعاني نقصا حادا في الادويه والمستلزمات
العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه المتعلقه
بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من
معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد
الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
نشير اذا الى هذا العاجل اسفل الشاشه
المبعوث الامميه للسودان فولكربرتز يقول
بان الجيش والدعم السريع وافق على ارسال
مندوبين للتفاوض اذا الجيش والدعم السريع
وافق على ارسال مندوبين للتفاوض وفق
المبعوث الاممي للسودان فولكربرت في اخر
تصريحاته طبعا التصريحات الاخيره للمبعوث
الاممي الى السودان كان اكد في تصريحات
سابقه بان طرفي الصراع منفتحان على الحوار
وكان قال تقريبا في ايام وساعات سابقه بان
الجانبين رشحاه مبعوثين لمفاوضات مرتقبه
خارج السودان وكان لفت ايضا بانه ليس هناك
اي جدول زمني لهذه لهذه المحادثات رغم انه
كان في محاولات مستمره لاقناع الجانبين
على التفاوض فيما بينهما اذا في جديد ايضا
الاخبار العاجله التي تردنا على لسان
المبعوث الام السودان وفقا لسوشيت برس
يقول بانهم يعملون على تامين وقف اطلاق
النار برقابه وطنيه ودوليه الى جانب
تصريحاته التي يقول فيها بان المفاوضات
ستركز على وقف اطلاق النار بشكل مستمر
وموثوق ايضا وها هو المبعوثان يقول في اخر
تصريحاته لانهم سيعملون على تامين وقف
اطلاق النار برقابه وطنيه ودوليه طبعا هذه
الانباء وهذه المعلومات ننقلها لكم وما
زلنا نشاهد اعمده النار
والتصاعد الدخان الكثيف في سماء العاصمه
السودانيه في الساعات المقبله ربما ستتضح
المزيد والمزيد من المعلومات حول طبيعه
وحيثيات
اللقاء والتفاوض الذي اعلن عنه اليوم
والان على لسان المبعوث الامومه الاممي
وارسال المندوبين اين سيكون هذا التفاوض
وما هو السقف الزمني له الساعات المقبله
ربما ستكشف لنا المزيد
في هذه الاثناء اعلن برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي عن استئناف انشطته في السودان
لتقديم المساعدات العاجله في ظل تدهور
الوضع الانساني في البلاد من جهاتها قالت
المديره التنفيذيه للبرنامج سندي مكان
قالت على حسابها في تويتر ان الازمه
الحاليه في السودان تدفع الملايين الى
هاويه الجوع ادى لرفع التعليق الموقت
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان وفي
منتصف ابريل الماضي قال البرنامج انه اوقف
مؤقتا جميع انشطته في السودان بعد مقتل
ثلاثه من موظفيه في الشبكات بين الجيش
السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه
وجديد الاخبار المتعلقه بتصريحات المبعوث
الامم للسوداني يقول بان المفاوضات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع ستعقد في السعوديه
على الارجح كما يقول المبعوث الاممي
للسودان طبعا نذكر بان الهدنه الاخيره
والتي تمديدها ايضا لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
تمت بمبادره سعوديه امريكيه وتقوم ايضا
السعوديه بجهود الاجلاء خصوصا وان عمليات
مغادره الرعايه وايضا مغادره الراغبين في
الهروب من البلاد املا في البحث عن ملاذ
امن لهم كانت تمر عبر السعوديه ومنها الى
بلدانهم طبعا نتابع معكم هذه التصريحات
فقط لكي نذكر بابرز ما قاله المبعوثه
الامامي للسودان فولكربرتز قبل قليل بان
الجيش ودعم السريع وافق على ارسال مندوبين
للتفاوض واكد ايضا بان طرفي صراع منفتحان
على الحوار ان المفاوضات بين الجيش ودعم
السريع ستعقد في السعوديه على الارجح نعود
الى مساله برنامج الغذاء العالمي الذي
اعلن استئناف انشطته في السودان بعد ان
علقها في الفتره السابقان تنضم الينا عبير
عطيفه المتحدثه الاعلاميه ومديره الوحده
الاقليميه للاعلام في برنامج الغذاء
العالمي استاذ عبير مرحبا بك معنا في سياق
هذه النشره ما هي المعطيات التقييمات التي
اخذها الغذاء العالمي بعين الاعتبار حتى
يعود ويستانف عمله في السودان
طبعا في
ضوء التدهور في
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طيب استاذه عبير طالما تتحدثين بانه قبل
اندلاع الصراع كان اصلا هناك اعداد قياسيه
تعاني من الجوع في السودان بالتالي تفاقمت
ازمه الجوع في السودان الان فما هي
اولويتكم بالنسبه لاغذاء عالمي لايصال
المساعدات كيف سيتم اليه الايصال بالنسبه
لي اولويه المحتاجين
اطلاق النار وهدنه حتى نستطيع الوصول الى
هؤلاء والتركيز سيكون على المناطق المناطق
الموجوده في شرق السودان والسكان وعمليه
النزوح التي يعني وصلت الى شق البلاد طبعا
بالاضافه الى هذا البرنامج سيقوم بتوزيع
منتظم للغذاء في
الدول التي بدات التنظيف للاجئين وعلى
الاخص مع التركيز طبعا على
هؤلاء الذين فروا الى جنوب السودان والى
الحدود التشاديه
[موسيقى]
الايام المقبله ستشهد عمليات توزيع في
مناطق مثل النيل الابيض كساله والقضاريف
وهي هذه هي البدايه على طب استاذه عبير
الكل يتحدث عن البحث عن ممرات امنه نقابه
اطباء السودان الهلال الاحمر السوداني
وغيره ماذا عن برنامج الغذاء العالمي هل
يتواصل وهل من تواصل مع كافه الاطراف
المتحاربه لتوفير هذه الممرات التي
تناشدون وتطالبون بها
المنظومه فهناك طبعا تفاوض من قبل الامين
العام ومن قبل
المبوط الامم للسودان وضغط من كل المنظمات
الانسانيه وبالتالي الجميع وسائل الاتصال
مفتوحه مع السلطات والفصائل المتصارعه في
السودان حتى نص الجميعا الى حل
يسمح لنا
بالدخول الامن الى من يحتاجها الى هذه
المساعدات الاحتياجات ليس فقط غذائيه
ولكنها صحيه وادويه
ويعني يعني كل الاحتياجات الانسانيه
وبالتالي نحن نعمل في منظومه متكامله وتحط
مظله الامين العام للوصول الى حل
يسمح لنا بهدنه ان لم يكن حتى انهاء العنف
نحن نشكرك جزيل الشكر عبير عطيفه المتحدثه
الاعلاميه ومديره الوحده الاقليميه
للاعلام في برنامج الغذاء العالمي
[موسيقى]
وهذه وقفه ومتابعه لابرز الاخبار الدوليه
تستعد النقابات في فرنسا لاحياء يوم
تاريخي لعيد العمال اذ تتوقع نزول ما يصل
الى مليون ونصف المليون شخص الى الشوارع
لمواصله الاحتجاج رفضا لقانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس ايمينيال مكروه
وقال لمين العام للاتحاد الديمقراطي
الفرنسي للعمل قالوا انهم يتوقعون مشاركه
مئات الالاف من المتظاهرين وضحا ان
النقابات اعد 300 نقطه تجمع في مختلف
ينحاء البلاد لاحياء عيد الاول من مايو من
جهتها تتوقع السلطات نزولها نحو 650 الف
متظاهر من ضمنها ما بين 80 الى 100 الف في
باريس وحدها كما اكدت ان اثني عشر الف
عنصر من الشرطه سينتشرون لضمان الامن
نذهب الى باريس الان ومعنا من هناك مدير
مكتب العربيه وحسين قنيبر حسين مرحبا بك
معنا في سياق هذه الساعه هل بدات مظاهر
الاحتشاد في العاصمه الفرنسيه استعداد
النقابات لاحياء هذا اليوم التاريخي لعيد
العمال واحتجاجا مع قانون
نعم اهلا بك نادين نترك الكلمه فورا
للصوره انا هنا في ساحه الجمهوريه
التي ستنطلق منها التظاهره من هنا الى
ساحه فارسيه اخرى هي ساحه لناسيون ساحه
الامه اعداد كبيره من المتظاهرين يتجمعون
هنا
للانطلاق بعد حوالي الساعه من الان
وهؤلاء طبعا التظاهر المركزيه في باريس هي
واحده من 300 موكب احتجاجي عبر فرنسا كلها
التظاهرات تشمل بالاضافه الى باريس كلا من
اليوم ومارسيليا ومونبوليي وانيس وكان
وتلوث وليل وستراسبور وايضا رن ونوت
وبوردو وكلير
والهدف تحريك الشارع مجددا رغم قرار
المجلس الدستوري الذي صدر في الرابع عشر
من الشهر الماضي والذي اعتبر ان البنود
الرئيسيه في قانون رفع سن التقاعد هي بنود
لا تخالف الدستور رغم ذلك التحرك ما يزال
مستمرا كما تشاهدون معي
خوفا من ان لا يتم هناك حصول اشتباكات
ربما
نعم هناك 12,000 عنصر امن بين شرطي ودركي
سيتولون المواكبه الامنيه للتظاهرات في
باريس والمدن الاخرى من بينهم 5000 في
العاصمه وحدها احد النقبيين سيتحدث لي
سريعا موجود
كيف تفسر استمرار تحرككم رغم قرار المجلس
الدستوري الذي اعتبر قانون رفع سن التقاعد
غير مخالف للدستور
الى لاننا نعتبر ان المجلس لم يفعل لم يقم
بعمله كما يجب الى بتوته
الشعب لم يعترف بقراره والمجلس لم يقم
بعمله كما يجب
لماذا انت ضد رفع سن التقاعد علما انه في
ايطاليا 67 عاما في المانيا 66 عاما وفي
اسبانيا 65 عاما في فرنسا هو فقط
الحكومه رفعه الى 64
لانه في سن الاثنين وستين عاما على الاقل
50% من الفرنسيين يصبحون متعبين ميرسي
بوكو هذا بعض من الصوره هنا نادين شكرا
دائما حسين مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنساوي
بالتاكيد سنكون معك في سياق النشاط
المقبله
كشف قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان
الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه طردت قوات
روسيه من بعض المواقع في بخموت شرق البلاد
لكن رغم ذلك اشار ان الوضع لا يزال صعبا
واكد ان وحدات الروسيه جديده تشمل مظليين
ومقاتلين يتم الدفع بهم مع استمرار
المعركه في مخموت القائد الاوكراني واضاف
ايضا ان روسيا غير قادره على السيطره على
مدينه بخموت رغم استمرار الحرب لشهور
بعد ان دعا مسؤول اوكراني المدنيين الى
البقاء في الملاجئ مع اطلاق سفارات
الانذار لنحو ثلاث ساعات من ساعات الصباح
الاولى اكد القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ان دفاعاتهم اسقطت 15 صاروخا روسيا من اصل
18 موضحا ان كل الصواريخ الروسيه التي
حاولت استهداف كييف تم التصدي لها ولا
اصابات وقعت على اثرها حسب المعلومات
الاوليه كما افادت وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه عن وقوع انفجارات كبرى في
مناطق اخرى
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره دفاع روسيا استهداف
عده مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش الاوكراني في
دنياتك واكد المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه
ان القوات الروسيه قامت بشن غارات على
ثلاثه مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش الاوكراني
مضيفنا ان القوات الاوكرانيه تتكبدت خسائر
بشريه وصلت الى 60 شخصا
تسببا انفجار عبوه ناسفه في منطقه اون شاب
مقاطعه بريانسك الروسيه الى خروج قطار عن
مساره ويعد الحادث واحده من الهجمات التي
تشهدها مقاطعه بريانسك الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا وذكر حاكم مقاطعه بريانس ان
الانفجار وما اعقبه من خروج قطار عن مساره
لم يسفر عن وقوع اي اصابه
بحث وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي مع
نظيره السوري فيصل مقداد بحثا جهود
المبذوله لاطلاق دورا عربيا قيادي للتوصل
لحل سياسي للازمه السوريه وذكرت الخارجيه
الاردنيه ان لقاء الوزيرين الذي بحث فيه
عده قضايا ثنائيه منها امن الحدود ومكافحه
تهريب المخدرات جاء قبيل انطلاق اعمال
اجتماع عمان التشاوري والذي تستضيفه
الاردن ويشارك فيه وزراء خارجيه السعوديه
وسوريا والعراق ومصر
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الساعه الاخباريه لكن
تغطيه اخبار السودان مستمره والان سيكون
معكم زميلنايا في الاحمر اليك نايف شكرا
لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات